[Music]
all right let's go to ronda help help me
rhonda in oklahoma city what's up rhonda
hi dr john how are you
i'm rocking on until break it down all
right fantastic
um things going okay doing all right
doing all right very cool so what's up
well i i watched a show a while back
looking at gas lighting in the movie
tangles
my husband and i have been married over
10 years now and he is
an expert gaslighter and i've been
through
counseling
and my husband and i have worked through
a lot of things and while it's not as
personal feeling as it once was the gas
lighting is still common
i'd like your advice on what to do when
it is happening
okay so okay this is um some behind the
curtain stuff
um whenever
they came the team came and said hey we
want you to do some of these react
videos i was like dude no one's gonna
watch this
and so you're telling me that you
watched the tangled one
i did okay and
you recognized oh man this is us this is
me this is my husband
yeah give me an example uh that you make
you just made the whole team feel good
and you make me feel i have to say i was
wrong so i said no one's gonna watch
this i was wrong
um that's my one time i'll say that for
2022. so
tell me what it looks like give me an
example or two of your husband
gaslighting you as an expert
yes as an expert um well
um one thing is just if i ask a direct
question it could be something as simple
as
i go to the store tonight he'll
you know ask me like what do you mean go
to the store or um just make me feel
like i'm crazy for asking a question
um
something else might be
if i'm
going out with a family member or friend
you know he'll make some comment like um
well what's she gonna wear tonight or
somehow implying that it's it's
inappropriate
so does it have to do with is he just
poking at you is he belittling you or is
it his way of saying i don't want you to
go but he doesn't have the courage to
state his needs out loud so he just he
constantly makes you feel a little bit
off-kilter and a little bit nuts
i think it's that last one okay
okay
um or when you say hey are you gonna go
to store tonight is that you asking him
somewhat passively
hey i need some help around here could
you run to the store for me or does he
have keys in hand he's walking out the
door and you just ask hey where are you
going
no he's actually super helpful and it's
more
um i think he puts pressure on himself
and so sometimes he's reading something
into it that's probably not there
oh like you might be accusing him or
uh yeah i think you might see it that
way
so
again i'm gonna
grossly over generalize this
when it comes to men and women but
many folks especially men don't know the
language of feelings
what i mean by that is
something happens somebody asks them a
question they experience a thing
somebody asks them hey will you help me
with something and they don't want to do
it they can't do it um they don't have
time to do it and so they feel
uncomfortable either they feel
uncomfortable because they can't meet
somebody's needs they can't they don't
know how to do something and they feel
less than whatever the thing is they
don't they're not well versed in the
language of feelings
and so
this thing happens to their body and
they begin to look externally this is
somebody else's fault
right
and that's where you
come in
for whatever reason you ask that one
question and he feels a certain way
doesn't know how to look in the mirror
and say these are my feelings happening
to my body about my issues it's nothing
to do with my wife
and but it respo the response is
she's making me feel this way so i've
got to turn this back around on her does
that sound right
it sounds exactly right
okay so
what do you do what have you tried in
the past that has worked or hasn't
worked
um i've tried a lot of things some have
worked and some haven't worked um
definitely trying the same thing does
not work right
some things that work better than others
is if i you know sometimes i'll just
simply ignore it and just kind of move
on
and i feel like that can sometimes build
up over time though if it's not
addressed
um
sometimes if it feels more intense i'll
just
exit
um so let me just
point this out to everybody listening
avoidance is
unless you're avoiding a bullet right
you're avoiding physical harm
relational avoidance
almost
never helps
yeah right it almost sometimes it takes
it's not the right moment like if
somebody's really fired up this isn't
the moment to have a deep conversation
but not circling back and avoiding it
long term is never a good idea right um
so you've tried that doesn't work what
else
um probably some of the best success is
if i follow up with a question like what
makes you think that or what makes you
ask that sometimes he'll be more open to
it
um
often he'll he'll just and it's in it's
like you mentioned certain topics are
more sensitive than others and so it's
kind of those landmine topics that he
just
really puts up a big
wall okay
so i want to flip the gaslighting
conversation around for you okay
less about how you can deal with him
and more about you
okay
so here's the path forward i think when
it comes to gaslighting
you get very very clear
about your worth
you get very very clear about
i'm worth more than being talked to like
this
or i'm not crazy
stop talking to me like i'm crazy
my request for you i'm your wife i need
some help with fill in the blank
um become very clear about what you like
and what you don't like
the nerd word is these are just needs
here's what i need i need you to not
come home and try to grope me when
you're covered up in oil or whatever
from changing that like like i don't
need that right or i need you to yeah
that sounded kind of weird i was
thinking about car oil not like um
been in the booth was started laughing
i'm not that kind of oil it's not
talking about
um
but i need you to help with the dishes i
need you to help right so what what do
you like what do you not like
and then also this is important and this
gets left out of the uh gaslighting
conversation a lot
you have to learn to be comfortable
with saying i was wrong i messed up
taking ownership of the times you do
like
you know withhold or you're angry or you
snap it like whatever you fly off the
handle coming back and saying nope
that's not gaslighting i just i was mean
i'm sorry right
um
and then you have to get over this idea
that it's your responsibility to make
him feel good about himself
is that fair
yes that's fair
and so
then you land there
um
you said things are getting a little bit
better
yes tell me what that means
um so there's some things and one of the
big issues for me was
um i really wanted kids and um
and quite frankly that one i just had to
um
decide you know if i could live with him
without kids and and i did so
i think that has calmed things down a
little bit because he feels more secure
that i've made that decision can we
pause right there
yes have you grieved that
i'm in the process okay okay
yeah um if you don't if you just make a
logical mathematical decision
that resentment will build up over time
and will become highly explosive
or worse it becomes toxic right so
explosive is we have this big blowout
somebody cheats on somebody it's a big
explosion
toxic is we just slow drip
dis dislike and disgust and get away
from me and you're gross and ugh and you
see him make a face and you interpret
that negatively and he interprets your
words right it just poisons everything
if you don't grieve it and say i wanted
kids and i had a picture of our live
having kids and it's not going to happen
and i'm choosing to stay in a
relationship where it's not going to
happen
and so ultimately the choice is mine and
i'm making it and i'm going to grieve it
and then we're going to move does that
make sense so make sure that you spend
time
changing that picture for yourself okay
good
okay so
you're dealing with that in process
right
okay does he know that
all he's quote unquote getting what he
wants he didn't want kids did you know
that going in
you know
okay yeah no we had talked about before
and it changed so that was one of the
hard things yeah
okay
does he have a language for i made a
choice that is
um
an existential
pain for my wife
i don't think so i think it's um
it's it's just a lot of fear okay
he's gotta take ownership of that
doesn't mean it was the wrong choice for
y'all does it mean he's a bad guy
but he has to own i made a choice
that hurt my wife and her soul
and she chose to feel that hurt and stay
with me anyway but i did i i made a
decision that
was a what caused my wife to hurt he's
got to own that otherwise the deflection
mechanism is gaslighting
yeah right that's the only way to keep
an arm's length from knowing i hurt
somebody is just to make them feel nuts
all the time
yeah
a lot of sense okay
um
have you gotten good about being very
clear i am getting better okay all right
good it is taking practice um so yes
um one one thing that came up somewhat
recently is
the resentment thing and i had a hard
time
conveying that i was frustrated
with the decision
um without him recognizing how big of a
decision it was
and without it him going straight to
well you can divorce me or you can do
these kind of things and and i don't
want to go there but
um actually
um
i read that clause reals book
and um
and
just came to him and said i feel like i
am going to resent you at some point if
you don't work out this stuff right and
um
and still to be determined how much
that's sunk in or not yeah so so can i
ask you this
the way you just phrased that i think is
really important
i think i'm gonna resent you if you
don't do this stuff
and the way you said
it's still to be determined tells me
he's not doing the stuff
and so the question i have for you is
does this ultimately end with you
leaving
or does this ultimately end with you
leaving psychologically but staying
physically
and just that's why i'm yeah that's what
i'm afraid of
but it's a fear that you can control
right
and so i'm scared of a lion
you have the choice to say i'm gonna do
the hard work and set this thing down
or i'm gonna leave
it's the middle ground that's gonna make
you insane
and quite frankly you're gonna poison a
guy who just said here's what i need i
need to not have kids
and i'm not letting him off the hook if
he was on the phone by the way we'd be
having this opposite conversation here
um ultimately this lands on you being
able to say your needs out loud
do not talk to me like that
i'm not accusing you of anything if you
feel like i'm accusing you i need you to
ask that question
i need you to go to the store for me
instead of were you going to the store
because if you're going i need you to
pick up some things so that's kind of
passive right i want you to become very
affirmative and i love the word you just
use practice this is probably something
you've never done before huh
yeah it's been practice yes good for you
good for you
um tell me a success you're having
um
one thing that we've worked out is
especially when we first got into
marriage um we were very you know
stereotypical roles and and i was
doing the cooking and that kind of stuff
and it just
we kept hitting a wall with it because
he wouldn't like it or whatever and so
he has taken over the cooking and i do
the dishes and it really works well it's
a good partnership there
yes outstanding excellent excellent so
y'all are practicing changing your
behaviors right not just thinking
through things but you are doing
different things
great that's awesome
and
it's okay if y'all can develop this
relationship i mean this this
communication pattern which i love
in our house let's say and i'll just use
my kids for example
they don't have permission in the house
to say mom this dinner is gross
because that's disrespectful and rude
they can say
i tried it and i don't care for it
that's factual that's fair they just
they're allowed to say that
there's a kind way to say things there's
a difference when you make food all day
and then somebody sits down it's like
this is gross
versus
um thank you so much for this dinner not
my not i let's go back to the burgers
let's do some right so there's like
there's a kind way to say things moving
forward
and calling one another to a more
dignified respectful way of interacting
with each other i think it's just
something you practice right especially
if you've never seen it before
right well that's awesome it sounds like
you're on the right track
i hope so
i want you to circle back to the very
beginning here
i want you to spend some time
writing down what you're worth
writing down very specifically what are
your needs what do you need from him
write down very specifically
how he broke your heart when it came to
kids
how it hurts
and it may be that one day with you and
a counselor and him you write him a
letter and say i need you to feel this
and you read it
and then that letter talks about how
much it hurts and how you had plans you
had you were going to go to graduations
you couldn't wait to
stand by your daughter while she got
married to some
knucklehead right you had these pictures
in these plans and they're not going to
happen
and there's something about reading that
out loud and then saying but i'm staying
anyway and so now we're gonna build
something totally new we gotta there's
no picture in the frame we gotta build a
whole new picture and live into it and
then that's gonna be your life's
adventure moving forward but you've
gotta stop in the grief section you got
to sit there and grieve this thing got
to grieve it and then we're going to
move on and then and then the more you
hang on to it that becomes an issue with
you
if you choose to
forgive
grieve and start acting start behaving
start moving in different directions you
can't circle back on and be like oh well
because it's done it's done and then he
becomes the victim there right so we're
gonna work together on this deal
good for you for challenging him for
saying no more gaslighting in my house
now i want you to go one step deeper and
decide
i'm got value and i've got worth
and i
am going to ask the people who are in
relationship with me and my home to
acknowledge that value and i'm going to
acknowledge theirs